[Music]
I think a great example of group
blindness in the United States is when
Woodrow Wilson said in 1915 in a very
famous speech there are no groups in
America America doesn't consist of
groups and if you continue to think of
yourself as belonging to a smaller group
you're not American it's astonishing
that he could say this these
Universalist tones at a time when Native
Americans were largely still denied
citizenship mexican-americans are still
being lynched Asian Americans were
barred from owning land and African
Americans were being subjected to
violence and degradation virtually
everyday and yet he was saying we don't
have any groups here so that's an
example of almost willful blindness to
groups and sometimes this kind of
Universalist rhetoric oh we're all just
one people is a way of hiding a lot of
inequality and smaller kinds of group
oppression so if you look at a country
like Libya they're actually a little bit
like the United States that is they are
a wildly multi-ethnic nation the problem
is they don't have a strong enough
overarching national identity to hold it
together and the goal is a group or a
country in this case that has on the one
hand a very strong overarching national
identity we're Americans
but importantly at the same time allows
individual subgroup and tribal
identities to flourish you should be a
country where you can say I'm Irish
American or I'm Libyan American and yet
be intensely patriotic at the same time
so I'm Muslim American I'm
chinese-american I'm Nigerian American
so at its best in America there should
be a certain amount of porousness and
fluidity across tribes it's when
tribalism gets really entrenched that
things can get very dangerous and
countries Western democracies at their
best or just any democracies are when
people have cross-cutting group
identities so it's like okay I'm a
Democrat or I'm a Republican but I'm
also
Asian American or African American or
straight or gay wealthy or not wealthy
just different ways of dividing yourself
so that you don't get entrenched in just
too terrible tribes it's sort of like if
I'm talking about sports I'm with you
but if I'm talking about food
preferences I'm with you and you could
have different groups that neutralize
each other one of the problems with what
we're seeing in America today is that it
seems increasingly that certain tribes
are hardening in particular you've got
what is very misleadingly called the
kind of coastal elites in a way that's
misleading because coastal elites are
not all coastal and they're also not all
elites in the sense of being wealthy
often in this term coastal elites is
included professional elites or even
students who have no money but they're
well educated they're progressive they
are multicultural and cosmopolitan and
we're starting to see in America
something that I've seen in other
countries that is not good we don't want
to go there we don't want to get to the
point where we look at people on the
other side of the political spectrum and
we see them not just as people that we
disagree with but literally as our enemy
as as immoral unamerican people because
once you get to that point you're just
not really one America anymore and you
start to get some of the problems that
you historically have seen more in
post-colonial developing countries so
when you have one group that is just
incredibly dominant for example whites
in the United States for almost 200
years a group that is dominant
economically politically and culturally
it can feel very stable but it's in an
invidious way that is that's because
there's plenty of tribalism and other
voices and other people and other groups
they just can't speak they can't express
themselves so you don't hear from them
so when you have a very strong group
that is politically and economically
dominant you can get a lot of stability
but that
often because other smaller groups are
oppressed
so take China China is a group with an
incredibly strong overarching national
identity over 90% of the population are
Han Chinese venue of all these
minorities the we Gers the Tibetans and
many many other smaller groups or tribes
but they have no power economically or
politically they can't say anything
their identities are suppressed in
countries where there's one group just
controlling everything politically and
economically you can have all kinds of
injustice and oppression but it tends to
be stable politically what happens in
other situations is sometimes power gets
split so in many developing countries
around the world economic power is
concentrated in the hands of a tiny
minority
for example the 3% Chinese in Indonesia
although only 3% of the population the
Chinese in Indonesia control roughly 70%
of the corporate sector and that's not
an exaggeration and almost all of the
country's largest conglomerates or take
whites in South Africa roughly maybe 10%
of the population for most of that
country's history under apartheid that
tiny white minority controlled
everything all of the wealth of the
diamonds and politics so these are
situations where you have minority
controlling an economy and what happens
in this situation is if you then
introduce democracy suddenly majority
rule you're not going to get peace and
prosperity like Americans often expect
democracy to bring instead you're often
going to get payback time where the long
resentful and suppressed majority will
use their new political power to come
after that dominant minority one recent
example is Iraq Iraq is a country where
the Sunnis were actually about 10 to 15
percent of the population but they were
economically dominant for many many
generations partly Saddam Hussein him
was a Sunni so he favored the Sunnis and
under Saddam Hussein's brutal
dictatorship the Sunnis ran the oil
wealth they controlled the political
power although a minority the Sunnis
were also dominant under the British
because the British like to play groups
against each other and the British
favoured the Sunni minority and before
that under the Ottomans the Sunnis were
also dominant so you've got this tiny
minority the Sunnis about 10% of the
population 10 to 15% suddenly the United
States comes in topples a terrible
dictator and says great we're going to
put in democracy now expecting democracy
in Iraq to bring freedom and prosperity
that's not what happened
the newly empowered XI is about 60% of
the population use their new political
power to exact revenge on the Sunnis who
had basically oppressed them for really
hundreds of years
so in that case democracy is not a
vehicle for freedom and prosperity but
democracy can become an engine for
ethno-nationalism and tribalism
[Music]
you